Gentlemen. Peralta are you eating an Italian
sub for breakfast?
I am, but Amy said I should eat more veggies,
so I got extra pepperoncini.
Smart.
Uh oh. Excuse me.
You need to watch yourself.
I'm sorry.
Cop. All right, let's everybody just stay
calm here. Or What?
Are you gonna arrest me for dancing?
You call that dancing?
Oh, this is dancing.
What is happening?
I'm diffusing a situation.
Dancing captain.
Must capture an image of a lifetime.
Oh, why is my phone always dead?
I paid $13 for it.
Don't worry, I got it.
Okay, Oh, My hands are covered in butter from
making butter. I'm on it!
Must record. Must record.
Camera on.
All right, here we go. Dancing over.
Situation defused.
Nooooo. Is, uh, everything okay, Santiago?
No, I lost my ring.
Did you see where it went?
Actually. It's behind one of these three
doors. Why don't you pick one?
Are you trying to Monty Hall Me?
It's unbelievable. I don't need Monty Hall
ruining my place of work when Monty Hall has
already ruined my home life.
Come on, sir.
The math thing isn't the problem.
Night shifts keeping you and Kevin apart.
You two just need to bone.
What did you say?
Don't say it again. I said you two need a
bone.
How dare you, Detective Diaz?
I am your superior officer.
Bone! What happens in my bedroom, detective,
is none of your business.
Bone. Don't ever speak to me like that
again.
Jake. Hurry up. I'm starving.
Sorry, sorry sorry sorry, sorry.
I just had to grab my walllll-et.
Gentlemen.
Fine. I was trying something and it didn't
work. And now it's time to send in our cute
little secret weapon.
I'm ready,
Captain. I love the nickname.
No, Charles, not you.
I was talking about Cheddar.
Oh, right.
Obviously. Over
The past month, I've had him trained to
retrieve plaques.
And now, boy, it's time to make daddy proud.
Yes, sir. I could not have been more clearly
talking to the dog.
Oh.
Good morning. Hi.
This is for you. Thanks.
Quite a big package you got there.
Oh, I apologize for the double entendre.
I can be such a Samantha.
Really? You don't seem like a Samantha.
Well, I'm actually a combination of all four
characters. Five, if you count the city of
New York. Yes.
Another sex and the citiot?
Guilty as charged.
My favorite season has to be the third one.
Everything was going right for Carrie.
Her face was on every bus.
Her column was the talk of the town, and she
met everyone's favorite furniture maker,
Aidan Shaw. Sure, she melted down when he
tried to introduce her to his parents, and
she flipped out when she bumped into Big.
Getting out of that cab with Natasha, whom
he had married.
Hmm. Who can blame her?
They barely knew each other.
The best episode that year was episode six
entitled Are We Sluts?
You know, the one. Carrie was all in her
head because she and Aidan weren't having
sex. Meanwhile, across town, Charlotte
couldn't stop having sex.
And Samantha. Samantha was just being
Samantha. The season finale that year was
entitled Cock a Doodle Doo.
Cock a doodle doo.
Roger that.
Whoops. I hate Big.
Carrie should have ended up with Mikhail
Baryshnikov. What?
He slapped her. Are you insane?
Bingo. Got the file.
Preparing for extraction.
No screaming, Peralta.
Did you ask me? They never should have made
the movie. Abu Dhabi?
Abu Don't-bother.
Wow. I'm gonna use that.
Please do. Have a nice day.
Okay.
Hey! Whoa!
Wait! Hold on! Stop! Both of you!
That pass is only for the ninth floor.
Is it? All right? Let me see that envelope.
Oh, um.
Actually, I can't show you that.
Because-- it's okay.
I asked him to come down and mail that.
I just need to put my return address on it.
And then there you go.
Thanks.
I know just where to put that.
Oh, there's Samantha again.
Are you ready for this one?
Dottie's daughter, Anne, is getting
divorced. I hate to say I told you so, but I
told you so. You know, we should fix her up
with Bernice's son.
What's his name? The doctor.
Oh, Vince. And he's not a doctor.
He's a pharmacist. Although that might
appeal to Anne. Pop pop pop.
Greg, you are such
A crack up. Forget Anne.
Who should we fix him up with, huh?
Oh, no. Cell. You know, I'm still getting
over the tragic loss of my wife.
She was such a strong female woman with
nice, heavy breasts.
I pity the child who lies beneath this solar
system.
Hey, captain. Something's going on with this
heist. You tell us everything you know, and
we'll tell you everything we know.
I'd rather not.
Joke's on you. We don't know anything.
Well, good day then.
Wait. Why are you sweating?
I'm not sweating.
I've had enough heart attacks to know what
sweating looks like.
That's Sweat.
Well, if I'm sweating as you claim, it's
because I was watching an exciting video on
the net.
Really?
But it was a video of an American gymnast.
His leotard ripped, exposing his butt.
It's highly erotic.
You're lying. It just install blocker
software. Thanks to moi.
Ah, yes, but they didn't install it on my
computer because I'm a captain.
You don't.
Look hot and bothered at all.
To me. Show us the erotica.
Gentlemen, I assure you, there's nothing to
see. Now, if you'll excuse me, I have to
grab some fresh air.
Good boy. Cheddar, bring me that cummerbund.
Wait a minute.
This isn't the championship cummerbund.
This is some common cummerbund.
You're not Cheddar. You're just some common
bitch. Diaz sent us the list of favors she
needs us to do for her. She didn't hold
back. First, she wants us to move all her
furniture into storage.
Okay. Then file her taxes for her.
And then she wants us to type up and email
these letters to Pimento in Argentina.
Are they sexual in nature?
Crazy sexual.
But we can't say no.
She's behind bars and we made a promise.
Right. You're right.
Oh, also, she's worried about her motorcycle
sitting idle, so she wants us to take it out
once a day. Here.
I think you should do this.
You're more the biker type.
I've seen you use a toothpick in public.
Motorcycles are death machines.
I have three kids.
I'm not risking it. Are you saying my life
matters less because I don't conform to
society's heteronormative, child centric
ideals? Are you really playing the gay card
right now? Yas queen.
Will you please read the transcripts of the
threats he's received? Yeah.
Die, die die, die, Holt.
Die!
Okay. Little obvious.
You will drown in your own blood.
Better.
Although I would have gone with the whole
"I'm going to staple my face onto your face
thing".
Human skin mask. Classic.
The next one is I'm going to send you off
the deep end.
Drowning and deep end.
Almost sounds like he's talking about a
swimming pool.
It's Hames.
Aha. Who's Hames?
Colin Hames, the freestyle killer.
He took out an entire four by 100 metre
relay swim team in 1982.
Marco.
Now you say polo.
Punk.
The freestyle killer, man.
How come all the killers you got had such
cool names? The best name I ever brought in
was Narrow Shoes Sam, because--
His shoes were narrow and his name was Sam, I
get.
It. Yeah, you get it.
Well, captain, it looks like you needed our
help after all. Together, we figured out it
was James, and together we're going to take
him down. Because together, we can do
anything. Here we go.
I'm finding Hames.
Alone.
Coming back at you, Jake.
It's 9 a.m..
Why is no one working?
Amy Santiago is a few minutes late, and we're
all trying to guess why.
I'd like to play. I'd say she's in line at
the bank.
This is fun.
It is fun. But you're all wrong.
She clearly slipped through a subway grate
and is having terrible sex with a mole man.
There she is. Amy, where have you been?
We've been worried sick.
Do you care to explain yourself?
I'm just 70 seconds late.
It's not a big deal. Don't worry about it.
Santiago, you will tell us and you will tell
us now.
There was a problem at the bank.
Hot damn!
Sir, we're tracking a triple murderer who
stole $21 million.
And all you can think about is Madeline
Wuntch. You're right.
What's that now?
Before I came to the Nine-Nine, I was rotting
away behind a desk in the public relations
department. All I wanted was the chance to
do good police work again.
I just got it, and I blew it.
Thinking about that devil toad.
I'm tired of politics.
Let's get that punk, Bludso.
This is amazing.
Of course, we have no idea where he is, but
I love where your head's at.
He has no family. Maybe there was a
girlfriend or someone he worked with at the
coffee shop. The coffee shop.
Why would someone who knows they have $21
million coming take a minimum wage job?
Because he needed access to that building?
Because that's where the money's hidden.
All right, we got to get there quick.
Maybe we should take the chopper.
You said chopper.
Death blade.
Sidewinder. It's go time.
Roger that, Wet blanket.
No.
From now on, call me Velvet Thunder.
Okay.
Relieved. For the first time all week.
It's just the two of us.
I'm right here. I escaped using some of the
lube Boyle sent you.
It got everywhere. I had to change.
Yeah, and
Your new shirt is very aggressive and
confusing. Is the pineapple the slut, or is
it calling someone else a slut?
Clearly, the pineapple is the slut.
Ah.